cam newton who as he was reminded
over the weekend by
a kid at a football camp that he was
either
producing or participating in you're a
free agent you're a free agent you're a
free agent he's a free agent he could go
to seattle and you know what he's done
well against seahawks in the past he
could stay with new england he can go
anywhere he he did a podcast recently i
think it's the im athlete podcast said a
lot of things that we posted plenty of
different stories about we appreciate
the content during a slow time he says
there aren't 32 quarterbacks in the nfl
better than him and he's right he's
absolutely right
that that's indisputable the question is
who out there is going to say
cam newton
is going to be our starter for 2021 and
beyond that's the question who's ready
to pull that trigger shireen
and somebody is mike somebody who
doesn't end up with one of these lottery
tickets
as a franchise quarterback is going to
pull that string and i i just went
through real quick in my head i had him
somewhere around maybe 22nd you know
there i do think there are some backups
in the nfl i think at this point we
would consider
minshew and dalton and fitzpatrick as
backups i know fitzpatrick probably goes
and gets a starting job this year but
they
we would consider them backups i think
um and those three i would say are
probably better than cam newton is
trubisky better than cam newton i don't
know you start getting those kind of
things but you know they do in the stats
they do rankings of of attempts
completions touchdowns yards all those
things and across the board he ranked
from anywhere from 18th to 34th of
course touchdowns was 34th below some
starting quarterbacks in the nfl and so
i put him somewhere in that range but
somebody's going to end up with him and
and we know that
passing wasn't his entire game mike he
was probably better as a runner this
year 592 yards and 12 touchdowns heck
even caught a touchdown pass so i agree
i think he's going to end up somewhere i
think he's going to end up starting
somewhat somewhere whether that's a
return to new england or somewhere else
mike
he admitted in this podcast that having
covert 19 affected him i remember when
he was asked by reporters after coming
back from covert 19 whether or not he
had brain fog he denied it but i think
the patriots at some level believed that
something was different and we still
don't fully understand how that disease
works we don't understand what kind of
impact it has he started the season well
and then had that surprise covet 19
diagnosis and never really did seem to
be completely the same first year in new
england complicated new offense not a
lot of time to get ready for it and i
think there is potential there for him
to be a very productive starter in the
right offense with the right team
whether that's back to new england and
it's already been reported as
a given that he's not going to go back
to new england he sure sounds like he's
willing to go back to new england and
that may be the best opportunity for
both sides but i think there's still
plenty of gas in the tank he was drafted
less than 10 years ago it was april 2011
when he entered the nfl as the first
overall pick in the draft and i really
do think that that he is better than
some of the guys we've been talking
about as starters for 2021 he made 3.7
million last year with the new england
patriots that's good money if you can
get it wherever you get it but for
starting quarterback purposes it's not
very good money and it shows that the
patriots got a hell of a value and it
may be the part of what cam newton is
trying to do this year shireen is make
back some of the money that he thinks he
should have earned in 2020.
yeah and he may not see that mike and
that may be the value of signing cam
newton frankly is you can get him for
less than you would get another starting
quarterback if you don't end up having a
high draft pick and getting a
quarterback if you don't end up with
russell wilson or sean watson or
whatever move you try to make cam newton
may be the best option for you because
he's not going to cost or shouldn't cost
a ton of money to sign just like he
didn't for new england you put a lot of
incentives in there and let him come
show you and you know we've talked a lot
even in in brady's final few years about
the weapons that the patriots had around
tom brady and the weapons that they had
around cam newton were not that great
maybe he goes somewhere else and maybe
he's a better passer in those places and
i do think covet played a part in the
season he had i also think mike that not
having a full offseason played a part in
the season he had you know he didn't
sign until july
and even if he had signed before that
they didn't have the on-field work that
they normally would have had and
probably won't have it again this year i
get that but i do think that played a
part in the season that he had
yeah i agree with you completely and one
of the ideas that i have for tomorrow's
pft live and we have more time to let
this breathe basically go through all 32
teams would you rather have your current
starter or cam newton for some of them
it's going to be obvious you're going to
want patrick mahomes you're going to
want lamar jackson you're going to want
josh allen but then at some point you're
going to start saying
i really got to think this through a
little bit maybe i would rather have cam
newton frankly one of the first teams
that came to mind for me is the detroit
lions and jared goff
all due respect i think i'd rather have
cam newton at this point than jared goff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports